Thank you for having us.
Can you start by introducing yourselves?
How did you form,
and where did your band name come from?
Who wants to start?
I'm Moeka Shiotsuka,
and I play guitar and vocals.
I'm Yurika Kasai, and I play bass.
I'm Hiroa Fukuda, and I play drums.
We are Hitsujibungaku.
How did we form?
I was invited to join the band.
There were five of us at first.
It was during high school,
when I was around 15 or 16.
But everyone quit due to their future plans.
Fukuda joined first,
and Yurika joined in 2016.
We hadn't met before they joined.
But I reached out to him after
seeing him play drums for another band
and searched for additional members,
and that's how this group formed.
It's been about six years.
We've been playing together
for about six years.
It's been about six years.
The band name is something I came up
with randomly in middle school.
Oh, questions come from over here.
If you were to come up with a new band name
using two random words, what would it be?
Since we're hitsuji and bungaku?
(Hitsuji = sheep, bungaku = literature)
I think so.
I'd want to use English words.
I don't like kanji.
Sheep?
I prefer hitsuji.
Tsuchi and— No, that's not it.
(Tsuchi = earth)
Daichi and kaze?
(Daichi = land, kaze = wind)
Daichi and kaze? That sounds so spiritual.
Our element is earth,
You mean the shrine thing?
...and yours is wind.
She's talking about shrine fortunes.
So our band name would be
"Tsuchi to kaze." ("Earth and Wind")
Foreigners wouldn't get that.
They'd wonder what shrines are.
Well, I guess they know that.
"Tsuchi to kaze"...
What about you, Fukuda?
Well, I was in noise rock bands,
called Emergency Elevator,
and Emergency Staircase.
Emergency Staircase? Emergency Elevator?
Emergency Elevator was the band name?
Yeah, I formed the band.
Emergency Staircase? Emergency Elevator?
You did?
It was a noise rock band.
That's too funny.
But why?
I wasn't expecting Emergency Elevator.
Emergency Elevator, the noise rock band.
Might be good, though.
Hitsujibungaku would be Emergency Elevator.
Emergency Elevator, the noise rock band.
Since the band formed in high school,
you've worked together for a long time.
How have you influenced each other
as fellow band members and friends?
Since we've been together for six years?
Yeah.
We're more like brothers and sisters
in arms or siblings than friends.
You're right. We don't really hang out.
Yeah.
But we're all really different.
If we were in the same class,
we'd sit in different parts of the room.
We're opposites.
If we were in the same class,
we'd sit in different parts of the room.
We might not even end up in the same class.
Yeah, maybe not.
But we do learn from each other.
Like Fukuda always says,
"You should do what you want."
I think that's true.
Yeah.
And Yurika says,
"I'm not going to try hard."
It makes me think, "Okay, sure,"
but we do learn a lot from each other.
I used to be the kind of person
who never wanted to do things
that might reduce the quality of my work,
but Shiotsuka's way of thinking
and sensibility are impressive.
Shiotsuka feels things
much more deeply than I do.
I've really been influenced
by that. I respect it.
Thank you. You're making me
blush, but thank you very much.
Next question, please.
Congratulations on the release of your
Jujutsu Kaisen Shibuya Incident Arc
tie-up song "more than words."
Thank you.
With its incredible harmonies
and substance, it's a song full of joy.
What was the process
for writing this song like?
We wrote four different songs
and got feedback from friends.
This was the most trouble
we've ever had writing a song.
But as a result, we created something
without compromising on anything.
It's the first time I felt like
I really worked hard on a song.
Were any of you fans of the JJK manga or
anime before you were asked to write a song?
If so, do you have
a favorite character or scene?
Yurika, you said you read the manga, right?
Yeah, and also watched the anime.
What's your favorite character or scene?
My favorite character is Maki Zenin.
Do you know who that is?
She has glasses and a ponytail.
Oh, her?
I really like her.
Why? I think I get it, though.
She's strong-willed and hard-working.
She works just as hard as any of the boys.
She can't use cursed energy—they used
cursed energy instead of "magic"—
but she compensates for it
with her physical abilities.
She's a tsundere.
She works really hard, but she's actually
worried about her little sister and family.
I like that gap.
It's gap moe, then?
It really is. I really like it.
Do you have a favorite scene?
Do you?
I bought all the JJK manga volumes
when we received the offer.
The Grasshopper Curse made me consider
issues of coexistence with humans,
environmental issues,
and how only humans survived.
The themes were more thought-provoking than
that of other media I've consumed until now.
That's in the Shibuya Incident Arc.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you.
You've produced music
for other anime including
The Heike Story and
The House of the Lost on the Cape.
Did you ever expect your band
would create songs for anime?
Would you like to continue
making music for anime?
What do you think?
I didn't expect it at first.
Really?
If anything, I thought we'd be picked up
for live-action or movies instead.
Anime has a lot of cool songs
that get the adrenaline pumping.
Hitsujibungaku produces a lot of
low- or mid-tempo songs.
It's not something
I imagined we'd be doing.
What about you?
Anime tie-up songs tend to prefer
a mainstream rather than underground sound,
J-pop over alternative, which is something
I keep in mind when working on tie-up songs.
For the JJK song, I used
a four-on-the-floor beat for the drums,
which resulted in
a new sound for Hitsujibungaku.
It was a valuable experience.
For The Heike Story and
The House of the Lost on the Cape,
we performed the opening themes.
It was like creating a musical
version of those series.
We were asked to create
The Heike Story in song form.
That was a lot of fun, but this time,
we were asked to create an ending theme.
We were establishing our own world
while creating something
that matched the feel of the series.
I enjoyed creating something
that matched the feel of the series
while also including ourselves
and our own interests.
We got to do things we wouldn't normally
get to do or don't have the time to do.
In that regard,
writing songs for anime is interesting,
so I'd like to do it again
if we have the opportunity.
During the pandemic, your
interactions with international fans
have included the release of your
album and online concert Hidden Place.
What would it mean to you to
perform in front of a live audience?
Is there anywhere you'd like to perform?
Hidden Place.
We didn't get to perform
because of COVID-19,
but performing in front a live audience
is what concerts are really all about.
People often say how audiences
differ depending on the location
and how performances
change according to the audience.
That's unique to live performances.
Our audiences tend to be really quiet.
Even before COVID-19, we never really asked
our audiences to make noise or hype them up.
It felt like our audiences were quietly
and intently listening to us perform.
Yeah, you're right.
But even if the pandemic hadn't happened,
we're older now. Our music has changed.
Maybe it's because we were frustrated
we couldn't perform due to the pandemic.
But once it ended,
I realized how powerful audiences are.
They make noise. We experienced them
making noise because they wanted to,
not because we asked them to.
These days I feel so powerful
and energized when we perform.
Is there anywhere you'd like to perform?
I've been influenced by
a lot of English bands, so London.
We went to London recently.
It was a lot of fun.
I just really want to go.
I've never been to the US,
so I'd like to go.
I'd like to go to the US, too.
We performed in Canada a long time ago,
but Erika wasn't in the band yet,
so it'd be nice to go together.
There are a lot of places
we haven't been yet.
I'd like to perform overseas.
You've performed at a lot of festivals,
including Fuji Rock and
the upcoming SWEET LOVE SHOWER.
What are you most excited for?
Ready, and...
The other artists.
The food.
The performers.
The other artists.
What'd you say?
The performers.
I said the other artists, too.
You're most excited
about the food, aren't you?
Yeah, I am looking forward to the food.
Festival food is amazing.
Japanese festivals are amazing.
They have a lot of local food.
You get to eat
every region's local cuisine.
Do they not do that in other countries?
I don't think I've ever
eaten at a foreign festival.
Me neither.
In Japan, it's like heaven.
Is it just Japan?
You can eat and drink
all the local cuisine you want.
Fuji Rock is a little different,
but the breakfast is good.
We're really looking forward to it.
The two of you gave true musician answers.
I'm looking forward to the other
artists' performances, too.
You're right.
Yeah.
I've been to Fuji Rock a bunch of times
as a regular attendee, too.
I had a lot of fun this year, too.
Who was your favorite artist?
At Fuji Rock?
Shintaro Sakamoto.
Oh, he was great.
I was really impressed by Yo La Tengo.
He was great.
They were awesome.
Fukuda, you spent a lot
of time in the greenroom,
but you went to see artists
you really wanted to see.
We watched some performances together.
I've been to Fuji Rock three times.
At my first festival during college that I
attended with Shiotsuka, we saw Sigur Rós.
I'll never forget that experience.
I felt euphoric.
I felt like I was floating.
I remember talking about the cymbals.
You remember that so well.
I'd like to see them perform again.
Your music and lyrics
deal with dark subjects
while also feeling rhythmical
and emotionally intelligent.
How do you achieve that balance
between lyrics and sound?
Could you tell us about your songwriting?
I see.
The balance between lyrics and sound?
But the lyrics and sound
are always the same, aren't they?
There's that new song
we recorded the other day.
The lyrics are really dark,
but the sound is really bright?
We decided to make it brighter.
I feel like the lyrics
and music usually match.
They do. When we play
according to how we feel,
the energy level ends up being the same.
Yeah.
I always start by writing
the lyrics and music together.
Even if I haven't written
the whole song yet,
I can't write unless I know what I want
to say, so I always have a general vision.
Sometimes I include
realizations I have along the way.
But even if the lyrics and music are
opposites, I have a vision from the start,
so I think about
how to convey that as I write.
Although recently, I don't even do that.
Yeah.
I figure it out as I go along.
These days I start by creating
an arrangement in the rehearsal studio,
and take that the recording studio
where I fine tune.
Hitsujibungaku is often
mentioned alongside artists like
Soccer Mommy, Regal Lily, and Chilli Beans.
Have you ever worked
or performed with them?
Which artists have influenced you the most?
Yeah, I guess so.
We've performed with
Soccer Mommy and Regal Lily.
We haven't performed with Chilli Beans.
But sometimes we perform
at the same festivals.
That's true.
Maybe we're close in age.
Are they a little younger? I'm not sure.
They're cute, though.
Fukuda, you used
to play drums for Regal Lily.
Yeah.
So we must be close in age.
I'm a year older, though.
Regal Lily are younger than us in age,
but they seem more professionally
experienced in their careers.
Yeah, you're right.
I really like them.
When Soccer Mommy came to Japan,
we said we really wanted to open for her,
and we got to perform with her then.
I doubt she remembers, though.
But we still really like her.
Which artists have influenced us the most?
I have a lot.
Yeah.
But Yuck and Smashing Pumpkins
are the big ones.
Mine are the Stone Roses and the Pixies.
Mine are My Bloody Valentine
and American Football.
They're shoegaze rock indie bands.
I see.
You've been described as indie rock,
shoegaze, J-pop, and emo. Emo?
Does Hitsujibungaku belong to
any particular genre?
Is there a genre you'd like to try?
Punk.
Hitsujibungaku is a punk band.
We're punk.
Any thoughts?
We've been influenced
by a variety of genres,
whether that's shoegaze, alternative
rock, psychedelic, or post-rock.
We've incorporated
those genres into our unique style
to create non-instrumental songs.
I think those genres
accurately describe us.
Our songs contain those elements.
You're right.
But our songs always express
a tenacious or determined spirit.
Spiritually our music is punk, but
musically, we draw from all kinds of genres.
And that's how we're fooling everyone.
Do you have any goals or milestones
you'd like to reach in the future?
We'd like to perform a lot of concerts in
Japan, but we'd like to perform abroad, too.
I'd like to live outside Japan,
so I'd like to be able to work anywhere.
For example, I think it would be fun to
meet up in Shanghai or something.
I guess that's our goal, then.
We'll record in London
and then make our own ways home.
We'd leave separately, huh?
I think that would fun.
At Fuji Rock, I saw
the members of Yo La Tengo
pass around their instruments
or sit out for certain songs.
I want to expand
what the three of us can do.
Yeah.
Okay.
Last question?
It's the last one.
Do you have any plans fans should look
forward to, such as projects or album tours?
I hope we can perform concerts
outside of Japan next year.
We'd like to perform abroad next year.
Okay.
Please briefly answer
the following questions.
Okay.
Who's the top artist
in your playlist right now?
World's End Girlfriend.
Warpaint.
Imogen Heap.
What's your favorite anime?
Neon Genesis Evangelion.
'90s Doraemon.
Cyberpunk: Edgerunners.
I really like it.
I like it so much, I looked up bootleg
t-shirts because I wanted one.
What do you frequently sing at karaoke?
Sotaisei Riron.
Seriously? Okay.
Perfume.
Chihiro Onitsuka's "We Can Go."
What inspires you most?
Poetry.
You do like poems.
I personally value the word choice and
how we perceive things with our senses.
I really enjoy inventive word choices.
You're always sharing
poems with our fan club.
Yes, I do.
Next?
What inspires me?
Nature, I guess.
Things I hadn't considered about suddenly pop
into my head as I blend into my surroundings.
You're right. I'll sleep
while I'm writing songs, too.
Ideas suddenly come to me
when I'm spacing out. I get that.
I guess my answer is people.
Being with friends and lovers
gives me energy.
Getting something to eat
together energizes me.
What inspires you most when writing lyrics?
Oh, this one's for me.
Yeah.
My current circumstances, my memories.
These days I draw a lot of inspiration
from my relationship with music.
Sometimes movies.
Describe Hitsujibungaku in a word.
Simultaneously mainstream and underground.
Water.
That's what Fukuda said a long time ago.
Hush.
Why?
Because we're ever-changing.
Punk.
And that's that.
We're now going to play
the "Most Likely To" Game.
Okay.
Use these to point at the person
the questions best describe.
Here we go.
Okay.
Who would be the strongest
jujutsu sorcerer? Ready, and...
He'd be so strong.
He seems strong.
He'd be the strongest.
Why did you choose me? What does that mean?
I mean it in a very positive way.
You're broad-minded.
It's like you're
looking down on everything.
You have charisma.
Thank you.
Okay, next. Who would you most like
to fight with you in a jujutsu battle?
What? I... Ready, and...
Wait, what? Yourself?
Myself.
You're going to fight with yourself?
The phrase "asking yourself questions"
appears in a Hitsujibungaku song, so...
The enemy's going to show up while you're
asking yourself questions and kill you.
The phrase "asking yourself questions"
appears in a Hitsujibungaku song, so...
You're right. I'm sorry.
The enemy's going to show up while you're
asking yourself questions and kill you.
You're right. I'm sorry.
You're sorry?
What is it?
I thought we'd be able to coordinate
some kind of double attack.
Like, "Darn you!"
Together, like a double kick.
Oh, I see. Like this?
Together, then.
Okay, next.
Who's the best dancer? This includes
your impressions of the other members.
Ready, and...
I bet you'd be a good dancer.
You seem athletic.
Oh, that's why.
But you actually dance.
I do take lessons.
Who's the most mischievous?
Mischievous?
Ready, and...
Yeah, it's me.
Surprises.
You like surprises.
Who's least likely to share their food?
Ready, and...
Sorry.
Wait, what?
Who doesn't share their food?
Ready, and...
But none of us are like that.
No, but you do like food.
That's definitely true.
You share your food, though.
I do share.
I think we all share.
But, Yurika, you like eating the most.
When Fukuda likes something,
he really likes it.
For example, if he orders salmon,
he'll give me the vegetable sides.
You're right.
Who forgets their parts the most?
Ready, and...
You forget lyrics.
I do forget lyrics.
No, no. That's just a special
concert arrangement.
I see, I'm writing a new arrangement.
Oh, that's what that is?
Yeah.
Sometimes, I suddenly
get the structure wrong.
I sing during the chorus,
so I notice when it happens.
I don't have a great memory,
so thanks for always matching my mistakes.
Who wakes up the latest? Ready, and...
I wouldn't really call it that late.
He gets up so late.
Your active hours are shifted.
Right.
That's why you get up later.
We all wake up pretty late.
But sometimes you wake up early, Yurika.
Sometimes randomly, yeah.
You'll get up at five by yourself.
What?
One time you got up at five
to get in the hot springs
because we had to be somewhere at seven.
That's because I really like hot springs.
I was amazed.
Who finds new music
to listen to? Ready, and...
Yeah, that's right. I love music, and I'm
always listening to some kind of indie band.
I always wonder
where you find your new music.
Right?
I always wonder
where you find your new music.
We are Hitsujibungaku.
We'll do our best to make sure
we can visit your cities someday,
and we hope you enjoy the anime.
Thank you.